[Music]
every now and then i run across a story
that is so weird and disturbing you
wonder what is wrong with people
okay this news story uh comes out of
florida it happened just a couple of
days ago check it out
an ocala farm worker remains behind bars
this morning charged with performing
sexual acts on a donkey the suspect
confessed his sexual attraction for
animals james saw him without assure his
pants were down and doodle was right in
front of romero
that is so upsetting that is hands down
the creepiest
news story i've seen in years
and did you see the guy's mug shot he
doesn't even look sorry
he's proud
what kind of mentally unstable freak
would have sex with a donkey it boggles
the imagination to have something like
the hell was that
helen did you just catch a guy in the
audience
sorry conan it was an accident my fault
the hell you just
that's awful i'm so sorry sir i
apologize anyway as i was saying talk
about this news story what kind of sicko
would feel zero shame after having sex
with a donkey he's posing for the moment
good god what happened there sorry conan
i accidentally cut to the guy again and
i hit the sound effects
you have a sound effect of a donkey just
load it up
i am really sorry that is horrible
i'm a donkey lover until the day i die
alan there's no explanation for that i'm
just sorry conan
do we even why do we have an audio clip
of andy saying i'm a donkey lover till
the day i die well that's from that
political sketch we shot with andy
what republican party
i'm a donkey lover until the day i die
all right i
that's just a horrible coincidence i i
i'm very sorry it will not happen again
uh i like to have sex with donkeys not
me andy richter the guy on camera now
[Applause]
wait a minute andy that's not even from
a sketch where did where did that come
from uh it's from my voiceover reel but
i don't know why they played it now
sir again i'm very sorry nothing like
that will happen again we will continue
with the show and there will
be alan stop it
[Music]
i don't know what's going on in the
booth but knock it off get control of
yourself
all right we're not gonna bring up this
story anymore and i cannot apologize
enough i'm very sorry we've had it
as the mayor of donkey town i hereby
present you the keys to our city you
unrepentant donkey loving freak
[Applause]
i'm sorry that's from a play i'm
producing it will not i'm sorry you just
go go everyone out of here go go
[Applause]
wait don't
[Music]
they took the audience member with them
i i think they're going to have a party